sallie hold on I got a call Chris waters
hey how's it going man
good John how are you I'm good are we
gonna do this me in the middle thing I
think it's technically public property
right because it's on the creek
technically public property located
perhaps behind the largest house in
Indianapolis also bring eugenia prices
beauty from ashes if you bring a little
snack do you think Jimmy John's will
deliver if we give them the coordinates
hahaha alright thank goodness I wore my
speedo today since we're going on the
creek I'm gonna go swimming good morning
Hank it's Tuesday it's actually Saturday
but it will be Tuesday in the fullness
of time so Sara's new show with PBS the
art assignment just premiered what she
does is she goes around the country
visiting with working artists we get to
see some of their work some art
historical context for it and the man
that they give us an art assignment I
have to pick a friend and then meet that
person at the exact geographical
midpoint between the two of us now many
of you will be wondering how is this art
well you should watch the first episode
of the art assignment so anyway my best
friend Chris and I chose each other and
now we have to make our way here by two
o'clock it is 103 p.m. is are just some
guy going on a hike with his dog to
arbitrarily meet a friend that he set up
an appointment with three hours ago
there's a certain excitement to it
nervousness about it not gonna lie I'm
pretty nervous right now I think one of
the things this designer makes you think
about is public and private space like
on this side of the fence those trees
belong to someone but on this side of
the fence the trees belong to everyone
that's odd okay we have reach Williams
Creek leap in the road
there's trusty Maya the craziest thing
about this is that I'm right in the
middle of the city of Indianapolis the
city of 1 million people and like it's
just forest this is intense
I'm gonna have to get down on my hands
and knees not an easy hike no my hands
and knees trying to get through this
okay here we go
who down in the creek hey coming up on
the last spot honestly if I do not to
meet Chris at this point I would give up
because the brush is so thick I don't
want him sitting there you know worrying
about me or whatever Wow look at this
this is so beautiful
Wow yeah that's not something I live
seen today I heard a noise oh oh I see
him I see him some calling Jeremiah
Johnson some call him Davy Crockett for
what he is is a frontiersman and I think
he's wearing his fancy amsterdam jacket
like a spry jungle cat springing into
the spring snow Oh sick of Maya oh hey
Chris John hey good seeing you here good
to see you come in for the real stuff
I'm so beat up man oh let me just look
look at that outfit looks like oh I
thought my whole idea was to go as
someone who's really super professional
you know leather like maybe a
businessman who just got lost in the
woods
that's just so beautiful man yeah it's
such a cool thing that we wouldn't have
done today
no you know like there's no way we would
have ever done this thanks for bringing
the Jimmy John's so I brought you a book
actually that I thought you might enjoy
it's called beauty from ashes it's by a
rider named Eugenia price you've heard
of her no I thought it was gonna be an
unnecessary plug for the Faulkner star
no no it's just beauty from ashes oh it
sounds like a good book and it is a good
book a good made me think this is how
people traveled 100 years ago well and
agreeing to meet at a certain time and
not having any way to contact each other
if they can't you know I did feel like a
kid again though yeah I haven't felt
that kind of sense of adventure since I
was a kid it's fun need you out more
wow I don't know the Internet's its own
kind of adventure so we've met in the
middle we've had our lunch and now we're
gonna walk out together as in several it
was a delicious Jimmy John's out yeah
and what thank you to Jimmy John thank
you to Jimmy Johnson thank you to John
for bringing the wonderful novel that we
share take don't forget to be awesome
I'll see you on Friday
this is your video for Tuesday yes